the city of New Orleans and the culinary
world are remembering legendary chef
Leah chase her career spanned more than
seven decades she created a safe haven
for civil rights activists including dr.
Martin Luther King jr. CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Michelle Miller first
met mrs. chase more than 25 years ago
Michelle she also became a good friend I
know she absolutely did when I first met
mrs. chase she was already a giant in
the culinary world her signature dishes
of Louisiana gumbo southern fried
chicken and shrimp Clemons Oh brought
her worldwide fame but there was so much
more than food that made her an American
legend Leah chase was called the queen
of Creole cuisine and her palace was
Dooky Chase's if I wouldn't come in this
kitchen every day I think I would be
miserable born in 1923 chase started out
as a waitress in the French Quarter
before marrying Edgar ducky chase jr. a
musician whose parents ran a small
sandwich shop mrs. chase took over and
transformed it into a fine-dining
restaurant for African Americans in the
1950s what did this place mean this was
like a safe haven for all of us during
the civil rights era chase broke
segregation laws by providing a space
for both black and white activists to
meet in 2005 Hurricane Katrina destroyed
Dooky chase but chase reopened it two
years later people said well what are
you gonna do at your age there was only
one thing for me to do no matter what
you do on this earth you have to do it
do it well
Ray Charles thing about her
and she even served as the inspiration
behind Disney's first african-american
princess I cannot believe I'm doing this
her customers included Martin Luther
King jr. and two US presidents George W
Bush and Barack Obama whom Chase had to
chastise I gave him the gumbo first
thing he does take the hot sauce
you don't put hot sauce in my gumbo in
2016
Chase received a Lifetime Achievement
Award from the James Beard Foundation oh
my goodness wonderful for creating food
that changed the course of history for
good in this restaurant in some ways we
really changed the course of America and
I say we changed the course of America
chase died Saturday at 96 one of her
most famous sayings was to be a woman
you have to look like a girl act like a
lady think like a man and work like a
dog love that mural in New Orleans I
have to say you know everyone's asking
me you know is the restaurant going to
continue I'm assured it is her grandson
Duke we call him took the fourth he is
going to continue on and she kept
working right up till anything she
absolutely did every day was in that
kitchen peeling potatoes or sucking all
kinds of things it doesn't hot sauce
make everything better let me tell you
she told Obama yes he couldn't put the
hot sauce in but she didn't tell me that
[Laughter]